there seems to be a lot of artificial
intelligence that is coming into the
world and how does one accumulate that
into the general intelligence
singularity net and then how do how do
people access there's the general
intelligence how do they apply it to
their practices yeah this is a complex
story unsurprisingly so I mean we can
really look at what we're making is a I
guess a network of networks of networks
you know and in a way and of but of
course human life is that right the
brain is a network embedded in the
larger network of the body embedded in
the larger network of society in bed and
a larger network of the ecosystem right
so AI has multiple levels like that also
so I have the OpenCog system whose
knowledge representation is a network a
weighted labeled hyper graph and there's
multiple AI algorithms acting on this
common knowledge graph such as some
neural nets for pattern recognition a
logic engine today with abstract
knowledge and reasoning evolutionary
learning which evolves and creates new
things and these all work together on
this common knowledge graph which then
has a goal system associated with it and
you can try to choose actions that it
thinks will help achieve its goals given
the current context for the
understanding of the context and the
actions is given by all the knowledge in
this graph right so that's OpenCog which
in itself is very complicated and we
worked on for a long time in sum which i
think is quite good at generalization
and abstraction we're still working on
optimizing it but I think the core is
there the singularity net is a platform
in which multiple ai's may be based on
quote different principles can be
networked together so they can all talk
to each other they can all communicate
share data with each other outsource
processing to each other so these AIS
can provide services to outside users
that can be used in the backend the
various software products and websites
but the eyes can also outsource services
to each other
and complex patterns and so that's it's
another level of network right so I
think you need some a eyes in there that
have a fundamental power of
generalization and abstraction like
OpenCog does but this can then work
together with simpler types of AI and
they can coordinate together into a
network whose intelligence in a way is
greater than the sum of the parts I mean
so you can look at that sort of like how
you know different organs in the body
you network together and they each have
their own intelligence but the whole
obviously is more coordinated behavior
than the sum of the parts different
cities yeah as well then we're also
working on something called the die of
the decentralized AI alliance and that's
an alliance of different decentralized
art projects so singular you know is
ours which networks together OpenCog
with a bunch of other guys but then
there are other projects like ocean
protocol which is a blockchain based
decentralized data network there's sebum
which is a decentralized network for
genomics based AI there's deep brain
chain which uses blockchain for fast
training of deep neural networks across
many machines so we want to network
together these different decentralized
ad networks into a sort of network of
network so that's where we have network
of networks of networks and all these
levels it's complicated but that's what
we see in nature yeah I think I think in
different ways that's what we see on the
internet already so I think that's the
right way to think about it uh that
doesn't mean you don't need core
generalization and abstract reasoning
algorithms in there it's just that these
and in some ways you could say these are
the crux of it for AGI but all the other
parts are important too I mean just as
in your cortex there's certain micro
circuits that are really good at
abstract learning and reasoning but if
you just put these micro circuits in a
vat yeah they're just going to
abstractly reason about their own
abstract reasoning and in sort of the
vacuous loops right it's by putting them
in the network of the brain which is the
network of the body of the society of
the ecosystem that you're getting you're
really giving these abstract learning
circuits the ability to prove their
worth
yes okay I liked how you were describing
it it finally started coming together
more more for me and I and I and I like
that and hopefully for others as well
okay now is when when you feed a when
you're feeding OpenCog which has the
ability to abstract the reason when
you're feeding it and to do of some sort
how does it parse that and make sense of
what it needs to do within its within
its framework to bring about the result
the OpenCog can ingest a lot of
different types of knowledge so I mean
there's a language parser where it
parses out English language now into
nodes and links to try to represent the
semantics of that English language it
doesn't always work but sometimes
sometimes it does and you can also take
computer programs like little Lisp
programs or something and import those
and then they turn into nodes and links
and it's not in it and it's knowledge
base we also have like specialized data
importers four types of biology
knowledge for example or accounting
knowledge and so forth and these when
you import the data it it it goes into
the whole and it's organized into a
bucket of buckets know it's areas not
buckets it's organized into nodes and
links to each other it's or not never
the buckets no it's not partition the
exactly but then there's the reasoning
engine looks at the nodes and links that
came from data including vision and
hearing as well as databases and
language and the reasoning engine takes
those nodes and links that came from the
outside world and builds new nodes and
links okay and that's how okay and then
that's how you add to it yeah yeah and
then and then I mean what reasoning does
this takes empirical knowledge and then
generates new knowledge based on the
empirical nodes and then and then what
when you're when you prom when you're
adding the knowledge and then you're
trying to get what the
answer of sorts from that how does one
how does it compute there is a tool
called the pattern matcher in OpenCog so
if you want to find a collection of
nodes and links matching a certain
pattern you submit a query and it
searches the whole knowledge based upon
things matching that pattern and then
there's the logical backward chainer
which if you give a pattern it tries to
find things that approximately you
probabilistically match that pattern and
so if you're asking a question some way
or another that question is turned into
a crisp or probabilistic pattern
matching query that goes against that
that whole knowledge-based okay
and then now oh yeah we're getting
pretty deep in the weeds those yeah but
that's really important adding the
knowledge making the query and then
getting some sort of results and and
this is what I want to do a little bit
as the roots as the deep roots and then
also then I see the OpenCog with
singularity net able to work with the
different AI so yeah so I mean if
someone makes a great AI for say
recognizing patterns in videos or or say
for importing data from accounting
spreadsheets or something you want an
easy way for that to feed knowledge into
an abstraction engine like like OpenCog
grows and so singularity that makes an
easy way for different AI was written by
all sorts of different people to connect
together and I mean if someone else
makes a different reasoning engine with
different strengths and weaknesses
relative to OpenCog that can be there in
the singular engine and also then some
application you consult two different
reasoning engines and decide which
answer it looks better or one of the
reasoning engines if it gets stuck
halfway through doing reasoning you
could ask a question of a different
reasoning engine that could help it get
unstuck right so there's a lot of
potential to having different AI is able
to compete with and consult each other
when in a con
that were interesting compete and
consult with each other in the I
networks interesting and then the and
then the decentralized AI Alliance gets
in there as well so this is more new
this is your newest that that's that
that's that's new yeah we announced that
a few months ago but we're still forming
it I mean the idea there so there's a
bunch of projects are using blockchain
related technologies to make
decentralized AI networks that are owned
by the participants and democratically
controlled and they have different
focuses so I mean singular Tina is a
pretty generic framework for
interconnecting AI is now deep brain
chain for example is a decentralized
network that is really fast at training
deep neural nets and Shivam is a
decentralized network that specifically
gathers genomic data from people stores
it securely and then does some analytics
on the genomics data right so we don't
need to replicate everything they're
doing we just let an agent to note in
the singularity network talk directly to
a node in the Shivam network or deep
branch chain so if a singularity that
node needs some neural net strange
really fast an outsource that to deep
brain chain if a singularity net node is
analyzing genomics data and once more
genomics data it might ask the Shivam
blockchain hey do you have any data
filling these criteria that I could use
and then the AGI token which is within
the singularity net ecosystem can be
automatically converted on the backend
in to achieve um token to pay for that
and then of course if you have
reputation and rating like if if one guy
has written a bunch of great AI in
singular you know he has like a four
point five star rating then if he starts
to do something in chief um he should
get a high rating by propagation from
things already nuts so you you can have
both sharing of data sharing of currency
and sharing of reputation and ratings
among different decentralized blockchain
based and I related networks and I think
this is how you can build an alternate
AI ecosystem that can really take on the
the tech giant's whoa that last part
yeah but there's a lot to be done yeah
and it's it's not just knowing the tech
it's coordinating a lot a lot of people
with different philosophies ins in the
sentence oh yeah yeah that's right
I love that sort of cool when a query is
sent in you're not even then limited to
what open Coggins you Ares well that's
right then you can access access a whole
bunch of other networks and that's right
I mean that's how I actually shouldn't
be siloed off it should be open networks
connecting the other open networks and
learning and growing from each other
[Music]
you
[Music]